ich bin Soldat und das heißt im
äußersten Fall müsste ich auch mein
Leben geben oder riskieren um andere
Menschen zu schützen wenn ich auf der
Straße angegriffen werde dann bin es in
erster Linie ich der angegriffen wird
wenn Deutschland angegriffen wird dann
bin ich nicht Deutschland du hast doch
diesen annähernd eine Ahnung was es
bedeutet im Krieg zu sein bringt uns das
trotzdem dem Frieden entgegen wenn ich
jemanden eine Kugel in den Kopf
grundsätzlich denke ich wünschen wir uns
alle in der friedliche Welt aber wir
müssen die Welt aktuell so nehmen wie
sie ist wenn alle Gespräche geführt sind
jeder diplomatische Weg ausgenutzt wurde
ist aber trotzdem zu Gewalt kommt wie
kann man dem Einhalt gebieten das ist
für mich eine Selbstverständlichkeit
dass ich Deutschland verteidigen würde
wenn nötig auch im Garten Gewalt
[Musik]
wenn man behauptet dass man irgendwie
einen wehrhaften Nationalstaat braucht
besonders in Deutschland dann Zeug das
für mich einfach von
Geschichtsvergessenheit wenn man sich
Waffen und Panzer anschafft dann ist es
in erster Linie zum Töten dann ist es in
erster Linie für Krieg zu sagen wir
brauchen Aufrüstung der Bundeswehr
besonders in dem Maße wie es passiert
halte ich für kriegst
würdest du für Deutschland in den Krieg
ziehen niemals sagt Henrik Spieler von
der Linksjugend selbst wenn Deutschland
angegriffen wird will er keine Uniform
anziehen Janicki von der Bundeswehr
sieht das völlig anders er war schon in
Afghanistan im Krieg und sagt seit dem
russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine ist
noch mal klarer die Demokratie muss sich
verteidigen im Notfall auch mit Panzern
und Granaten
ihr beiden herzlich willkommen bei mir
auf der Couch Jan-Hendrik schön dass Ihr
da seid neben einem Mann mit Uniform auf
der Couch wie fühlt sich das an ja was
soll ich sagen also es ist natürlich
einschüchternd liegt auch daran wofür
sie steht ne also man kann eine Kleidung
natürlich nie beurteilen ohne den
Hintergrund zu können findest du das
mutig wenn jemand für Deutschland in den
Krieg zieht das heißt mutig es ist ein
ich glaube es gibt einen Unterschied ob
man etwas tut wenn man mutig ist oder ob
man sich so weit in Sachen rein schmeißt
eben weil man nicht mutig ist in den
Krieg ziehen es keinen Ausdruck von Mut
sondern eine Ausdruck von Verzweiflung
was ist eigentlich Mut das ist aus
psychologischer Sicht nämlich total
interessant weil es nicht einfach das
Gegenteil von Angst ist was viele denken
sondern mutig sein heißt etwas zu tun
obwohl man angst hat das heißt Angst ist
immer auch ein Teil von Mut was sagst du
sie ist auch so dass natürlich der eines
der das Militärs ist äußerste Mittel das
letzte Mittel ist was wir haben das
heißt dann wirklich alle anderen Ebenen
gescheitert sind dann muss das Militär
teilweise eingreifen
Henrik setzt zum Sprung an das klingt
natürlich super was du sagst finde es
aber glaube ich im Vergleich damit was
dann tatsächlich passiert und was
tatsächlich vor Ort passiert
ja einfach nicht realitätsgetreue also
wenn man einfach den Elefanten im Raum
nimmt beispielsweise mal Afghanistan und
sagt was hat da geklappt an humanitärer
Hilfe also es gab ja Ausbildung von
Polizeikräften zum Militär wurde
unterstützt und so weiter und so fort
und jetzt regieren die Taliban das Land
nachdem man ja einfach sprunghaft
eigentlich schon abgezogen ist aus dem
Land dann frage ich mich das ist
tatsächlich hilft wenn es beispielsweise
in Afghanistan oder auch im Kosovo ähm
im in der Vergangenheit schon nicht
geholfen hat wenn du im Rückblick jetzt
auf diesen Einsatz in Afghanistan guckst
hat sich das gelohnt ich denke es war es
wert einmal an der Seite unsere
Verbündeten zu stehen und zum Anderen
eben die Möglichkeit zu eröffnen dass
die Menschen eine Perspektive haben ich
selber habe dort unten Fluglotsen
ausgebildet die humanitäre Hilfe hätte
es ohne unseren eines auch gar nicht
geben können weil wir für die Sicherheit
gesorgt haben Afghanistan ist wenn man
in Deutschland sitzt gefühlt sehr weit
weg finde ich
uns deswegen mal genau den Fokus jetzt
in unsere Nähe legen wir haben Krieg in
Europa und da erlebe ich bei ganz ganz
vielen Leuten auch bei mir selber dass
man doch wirklich plötzlich wieder
Fragen nach vorne holt die vorher nicht
da waren und einer die ich dich ganz
zentral finde von der ich mir jetzt
wünsche dass ihr ganz kurz nur antwortet
ist die ob man für Deutschland in den
Krieg ziehen würde bevor die beiden
Antworten jetzt du würdest du für
Deutschland in den Krieg ziehen ganz
ehrlich deine Meinung in die Kommentare
nein ich würde definitiv nicht für
Deutschland den Krieg ziehen weil es
eben nichts tatsächlich mit mit
Wertevorstellungen oder sonst was zu tun
hat sondern weil es einfach die
Reduzierung meines in meiner selbst oder
meines Individuums wie auch immer auf
pure Nationalität und pure künstliche
Zuschreibungen ist ich würde definitiv
für Deutschland in den Krieg ziehen bei
mir das demokratische System indem wir
leben mit der gesamten Freiheit die uns
hier gewährleistet wird einfach so
unglaublich viel wert ist und ich dann
am Ende eben auch für diese knapp 80
Millionen Menschen und eben auch für
meine Familie dastehen würde auch wenn
es natürlich sehr schmerzhaft wäre ihr
beiden ich glaube dass gerade diese
Fragen in so so vielen Köpfen eine Rolle
spielen und tut mir den Gefallen helft
einmal ein bisschen umzubauen Platz zu
schaffen
[Musik]
würdest du für Deutschland in den Krieg
ziehen das klingt erstmal ganz abstrakt
und ich will das jetzt fest sagen ich
will das ganz konkret machen habe
plastikwaffen besorgt die beiden gleich
auch in die Hand nehmen müssen ich will
vor allem sehen ob Henrik am Ende
tatsächlich weiterhin ganz klar sagt ich
würde niemals eine Waffe für Deutschland
in die Hand nehmen
was haben wir vor mir ist wichtig dass
wir wirklich einmal versuchen
festzulegen was Momente sind wo ihr
sagen würdet da wäre ich vielleicht
bereit zur Waffe zu greifen die Waffen
die wir hier haben sind plastikwaffen
das ist völlig klar und das soll auch
nicht irgendwas ersetzen oder runter
spielen aber mir geht's genau um diesen
Akt dass man mal sagt okay da könnte ich
mir vorstellen für Deutschland die Waffe
in die Hand zu nehmen und dann habe ich
jetzt verschiedene Szenarien für Euch
dabei und wenn ihr sagt da würde ich für
Deutschland zur Waffe greifen steht ja
auf nehmt euch die Waffe setzt euch
wieder hin dass man dort läuft noch
würdest du die Waffe in die Hand nehmen
um für die Bundeswehr nach Mali zu gehen
um dort für eine unfriedensmission zu
kämpfen
und wenn das Parlament beschließt
dass die Bundeswehr irgendwo eingesetzt
wird also die Mehrheit der
Volksvertreter die wir alle paar Jahre
wählen
dann haben wir einen gültiges Mandat und
entsprechend bin ich also da dann in der
Pflicht entsprechend dann zu folgen du
sagst ich bleib sitzen keine Waffe in
die Hand nehmen definitiv ja was geht
dir durch den Kopf wenn du an die
Menschen in Mali denkst
natürlich ist es unvorstellbares Leid
was diese Menschen in Mali erleben ne
und das ist ja auch das was ich
irgendwie zum Ausdruck bringen möchte
das Krieg jeder Art egal wie wo wann er
geschieht immer schlecht ist für die
Leute die tatsächlich dort leben und es
ist für mich meistens nicht die Frage
gegen was für dich kämpft aber die Frage
ist für was für was steht man ein und
dieses gute für dass ich tatsächlich
kämpfen würde ich sagen würde ja gehen
wir rein dass ich nicht in Deutschland
und das sehe ich auch nicht in einem
anderen Nationalstaat ja macht's dich
sauer wenn jemand wie Hendrik sagt ich
lass die Waffe liegen Artikel 4 Absatz 3
niemand wird zum Kriegsdienst gezwungen
also entsprechend kann ich das nur
respektieren und akzeptieren es macht
mich nicht sauer mir ist es nur wichtig
dass wir sozusagen ein Fokus auf die
Realpolitik legen und ein Stück weit
weggehen von der Ideologie das ist doch
eigentlich das wichtigste Ziel dass wir
den Frieden anstreben und sagen wenn
alle strickel auf der diplomatischen
Ebene gerissen sind und wirklich nichts
mehr geht dann haben wir als äußerstes
Mittel als äußerstes Werkzeug in diesem
in diesem großen Koffer haben wir dann
das Militär die Frage nach Krieg ist
auch automatisch immer eine Frage nach
Politik und die Frage nach Politik muss
eine Klassenfrage sein deswegen ist es
so dass viele Leute aus prekären
Verhältnissen die keinen Ausweg sehen
die auch keinen Zugang vielleicht haben
so besonders guter Bildung oder zu
besonders guten Studienplätzen etc pp
dass die eben den Ausweg dann zur
Bundeswehr gehen ja du hast die Waffe
sofort wieder in die Hand genommen
hast du schon mal mit einer geladenen
Waffe auf jemanden geschossen zum Glück
musste ich das noch nicht tun was
glaubst Du würde das mit dir machen ich
bin Soldat und das heißt im äußersten
Fall müsste ich auch mein Leben geben
oder riskieren um andere Menschen zu
schützen wir können ja mal die
Feuerwehrleute oder die Polizisten
Fragen die machen das den ganzen Tag da
ist es vielleicht ein bisschen
greifbarer im Rahmen des Friedens
abstrakter 63% der Bundesbürger geben in
einer repräsentativen Umfrage an dass
sie sich Sorgen machen dass Deutschland
in den Krieg in der Ukraine
hineingezogen werden könnte und damit
kann man ja schon sagen ist es in vielen
Köpfen nicht mehr abstrakt Deutschland
wird angegriffen greifst du dann zur
Waffe
auf jeden Fall das wäre dann natürlich
im Verteidigungsfall nochmal zu
differenzieren wo ich dann eingesetzt
werde wahrscheinlich nicht im Rahmen der
Öffentlichkeitsarbeit sondern als
Offizier eventuell als Führungskraft
Deutschland wird angegriffen du sagst
auch da greife ich nicht zur Waffe was
machst du in dem Moment wenn ich
Deutschland verteidige dann verteidige
ich die herrschenden Verhältnisse in
diesem Land das möchte ich aber nicht
weil die Frage ist was sind denn die
herrschenden Verhältnisse und wo finden
wir uns denn wieder 14 Millionen Leute
in Deutschland leben in Armut möchte ich
das verteidigen oder sage ich nicht
lieber ich würde etwas verteidigen was
tatsächlich eine gute Institution wäre
die panzerrollen vor es wird tatsächlich
scharf geschossen man kann auf der
Straße angegriffen im getötet werden
greifst du dann zur Waffe
jetzt wieder eure Meinung ja klar und
Verteidigungsfall definitiv das war klar
wenn ich auf der Straße angegriffen
werde dann bin es in erster Linie ich
der angegriffen wird auf der Straße in
Deutschland angegriffen wird dann bin
ich nicht Deutschland besonders mit
einer Bundeswehr die immer noch unter
Symbolen wie dem eisernen arbeitskämpft
die mit rechtsextremen Netzwerken zu
kämpfen hat ist das für dich wirklich
ein Punkt wo du sagst das ist nie wieder
Auschwitz was wirklich nie wieder
Auschwitz ist ist das gute Leben was nie
wieder ausschwitzt ist ist die Aufhebung
von gesellschaftlichem Zwang von
gesellschaftlicher Depression und
Verelendung und das ist der Punkt für
den ich kämpfen gut alle an dem du das
an dem Punkt an dem Punkt muss ich sagen
da scheiden sich so ein bisschen die
Geister weil ich mir sage dass gute
Leben also wir haben jetzt wirklich das
absolute Glück und das muss man sich mal
vor Augen führen dass wir einfach in
einer sicheren Bubble groß geworden sind
wir sind im Frieden groß geworden sorry
du hast doch nicht eine Ahnung was das
bedeutet im Krieg zu sein was es heißt
dieses Leid zu erleben und zu sagen ich
würde Deutschland jetzt nicht
verteidigen weil es eine abstrakte
Institution ist die für irgendwelche
Werte steht bei allem Respekt die
Demokratie ist das Beste was wir seit
langem haben gibt es einen Moment Henrik
jetzt an dich gefragt wo du sagen
würdest dann nehme ich die Waffe in die
Hand dann sag's mir doch direkt dazu
wann das wäre
also ich würde die Waffe in die Hand
nehmen wenn es tatsächlich darum gehen
würde
die nicht nur die Idee sondern die
Realität tatsächlich eines menschlichen
eines humanen eines solidarischen
Systems einer solidarischen Gesellschaft
zu verteidigen und diese Gesellschaft
sehe ich eben nicht in Deutschland
sondern eben in etwas was wir momentan
nicht haben wo wäre denn ein gutes
Beispiel wo das so wäre wie das gerade
beschreibst ja eben gar nicht ich habe
gesagt das haben will allgemein nicht
okay das haben wir allgemeinig ja
natürlich habe ich freie
Meinungsäußerung und sonst was aber nur
im Rahmen dessen dass ich arbeite und
dass ich konsumiere und produziere nicht
jeder hat das Recht auf freie Meinung
egal ob ich arbeite nicht arbeite so
lange ich mich in diesen Grenzen des
Landes bewegen kann ich sagen was ich
möchte solange ich die linke und rechte
Grenze der freiheitliche demokratischen
Grundordnung
es gab damals als ich noch gerade Abitur
gemacht habe die die Musterung und da
gab es noch mal wieder früher Verfahren
wo man dann quasi sagen konnte ich will
nicht den Dienst an der Waffe machen und
da wurden sehr sehr
krasse sehr konkrete Fragen zum Teil
gestellt also ungefähr ging das zum
Beispiel auch in die Richtung deine
Freundin wird vergewaltigt und
umgebracht und gerade massiv bedroht
kannst du dann eine Waffe in die Hand
nehmen um dich zu verteidigen ja
definitiv aber meine Freundin ist nicht
Deutschland oder andersrum Deutschland
ist nicht meine Freundin das heißt was
ich in diesem Moment verteidige ist
tatsächlich mein Leib meine Seele und so
weiter und so fort für Deutsch aber
nicht solidarisch also sorry das ist
überhaupt nicht solidarisch aber warum
muss ich mir jetzt sagen dass ein
solidarisch ist und was nicht von einem
der für Deutschland kämpft ich kenne
auch für dich ich kämpfe auch für unsere
Meinungsunterschiede das ist doch
wunderbar du sagst du kämpfst nur für
deine Engel Familie und für deine sage
ich mal Freundin für einen ganz kleinen
Blase und ich sage einfach ich kämpfe
auch für deine Familie obwohl ich die
gar nicht kenne das ist doch eigentlich
sehr schön aber ich sehe den Zwang
daraus jetzt nicht dass ich das auch für
dich tun muss du sprichst ja die ganze
Zeit von Solidarität aber die höre ich
überhaupt nicht weil es im Grunde
genommen einfach nur um deine Blase geht
und du sagst okay da gibt es eine Welt
die wir uns vielleicht irgendwann
schaffen die noch überhaupt nirgends
gibt in deiner Wahrnehmung als sie mir
sozusagen Vorwurf entgegengebracht hat
dass ich unsolidarisch sei er hat es in
mir einfach Unverständnis ausgelöst weil
ich keine Leute beschützen möchte die
ich nicht kenne Zeit für die Couch ich
würde sagen Umbau helft mir wieder mit
[Musik]
wie würdet ihr gerade die Raumtemperatur
einstufen ich würde sagen zwei drei vier
fünf Grad wärmer ich glaube schon es
wird wärmer definitiv du bist
hochgefahren wo am meisten ich denke wir
haben sehr sehr viel Glück hier und ich
denke es ist auch wer zu verteidigen
auch mit den Institutionen die wir haben
ich sage nicht dass wir fehlerfrei sind
um Himmels willen darum geht es nicht
wir haben dort eine kleine Blase für
dich jetzt einfach mal zähle die sagt
nein ähm Solidarität ist sozusagen mein
enger kleiner Kreis und ich sage
Solidarität sind über 80 Millionen
Menschen und viele viele Europäer es ist
richtig Streit in der Luft das finde ich
gut und trotzdem gibt's vielleicht auch
Punkte wo ihr euch einig seid und einen
würde ich jetzt gerne mal rausgreifen
was passieren auffällt ist ja wirklich
wie viel Konflikte zwischen den beiden
ist und das finde ich großartig weil
genau dafür treffen wir uns und trotzdem
will ich ja auch wissen was kann man
konstruktiv tun was haben wir in der
Hand um den Krieg ein Ende zu bereiten
das ist das gemeinsame Ziel von den
beiden aber welche Wege dahin führen ja
darüber müssen wir uns jetzt streiten
und darum geht's
[Musik]
die Friedenstaube hängt wieder
symbolhaft ich glaube was anderes bleibt
uns heute nicht übrig trotzdem glaube
ich ist es ja auch eine Frage was machen
wir in Deutschland um den Frieden in der
Ukraine herzustellen was können wir dazu
beitragen Idee ist ganz einfach ich lese
jetzt Maßnahmen vor die nicht ich
erfunden habe sondern verschiedenste
Leute verschiedenste Kräfte in
Deutschland und damit ich euch bitten
wenn ihr sagt das bringt uns dem Frieden
näher dann steigt ihr auf der Leiter
nach oben Richtung Friedenstaube erste
Aussage wir sollten so schnell wie
möglich Leopard Kampfpanzer in die
Ukraine liefern
ich gehe mal vorsichtig einen Schritt
nach oben einen aber auch ganz klar
erläutern also ich finde es ist eine
schwierige Sache die natürlich auf der
politischen Ebene entschieden werden
muss zum einen liefern wir klare
Offensivwaffen an die Ukraine andersrum
ist die Frage von wem lassen wir uns
sozusagen diesen Konflikt Bestimmen von
dem Aggressor oder unterstützen wir
lieber eine Demokratie die im Grunde
genommen in Europa ist und uns um Hilfe
bittet die Forderung kommt von Anton
Hofreiter dem grünen Politiker und du
sagst nein keine Kampfpanzer die Ukraine
genau also stimmt dem der Analyse stimme
ich tatsächlich zu ach ne also Leute
kurz vor Umarmung
noch nicht ganz ähm trotzdem ist es
einfach ein enormes anflammendes
Konfliktes das ist ja nicht so dass wir
von Verteidigungstechnik oder ja
leichteren Waffen sprechen sondern das
war ein Leopard Panzer genau
das ist ganz klar die Frage ist nur wenn
jetzt Putin sagt ihr dürft nur
Schlafsäcke liefern
wäre das dann okay also wo wo sie wie
die Grenze das würde ich gerne verstehen
und natürlich gibt es Unterscheidung
zwischen schweren Waffen und nicht
schweren Waffen und deswegen auch eine
logische Entscheidung zwischen das
entfacht den Krieg nur noch weiter und
das bringt umso mehr Brutalität in
diesen Krieg ich glaube dass man
humanitäre Hilfe auf keinen Fall
unterschätzen sollte sondern das ist das
allererste ist was man macht das ist
aller erstes ist dass man die Leute die
tatsächlich auf diesen Kriegsgebieten im
Krieg mittendrin Leben und Wohnen
evakuiert dass man sie rausholt und dass
man ihnen konkret hilft ich würde den
Punkt gerne aufgreifen da haben wir
jetzt keinen konkreten Absender aber
humanitäre Hilfe für die Ukraine z.B in
Form von Schlafsäcken und glaube ich
noch viel viel mehr was wir tun können
wie sehr würde das zum Frieden beitragen
eure Position auf der Leiter
also ich gehe ein Stück weit wieder auf
die Leiter rauf es ist auch wichtig zu
sagen dass humanitäre Hilfe nur ein Teil
ist deshalb sage ich nur humanitäre
Hilfe wird nicht zum Frieden führen das
ist meine klare Ansage das Frieden mehr
ist als die Abwesenheit von Krieg und
Frieden ist nicht ab da erreicht wo man
sagt das wird nicht mehr geschossen
sondern Frieden ist ab da reicht wo man
sagt es findet keine konkrete humanitäre
Katastrophe und keine Spannung der Stadt
bezeichnet ist wir sind auf derselben
Stufe beide auch ein ganz schönes Stück
Richtung Frieden gestiegen und trotzdem
ist noch Streiter
Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen
[Musik]
ich gehe sogar auch auf eine Stufe
Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen aber mit
Erklärung natürlich die hören uns gerne
gleich an erstmal weiß ich nicht was du
jetzt sagst ob du da stehen bleibst weil
diese Aussage kommt von Björn höcke AFD
den werde so schön er kann auch sagen
die Sonne ist ein Stern und dann stimme
ich ihm auch zu der der Punkt ist
einfach nur dass ich nicht weiß warum
man sich den verschließen sollte ich
habe das ganz bewusst gemacht den
Menschen von der Linksjugend
konfrontieren mit einem AFD Zitat und
ich finde Henrik ist damit unglaublich
souverän umgegangen wer sagt nein ich
weiß es nicht hier steht jemand auf
Stufe 1 wenn du schon ganz warum
natürlich im Idealfall schaffen wir es
ein Frieden zu bewahren indem wir sagen
wir schaffen es über eine diplomatische
Lösung also ohne Waffen das ist immer
das Beste was für uns passieren kann
aber es gibt eben auch viele Situationen
wo man in einem Grunde genommen eines
Situation gezwungen wird wieder Krieg in
der Ukraine und ähm hier würde es den
Ukraine nicht mehr helfen auf der
diplomatischen Ebene nur auf der
diplomatischen Ebene zu bleiben denn das
hat ungefähr 7 oder 8 Jahren
mittlerweile probiert ist natürlich
immer die Frage was versteht man als
Waffe wenn man sagt setzt Diplomatie ein
wenn man sagt man setzt wirtschaftliche
Sanktionen ein dann ist das auch eine
Waffe dann ist es aber keine Waffe die
schießt sondern es ist halt eine Waffe
die anders trifft nämlich strukturell
nämlich politisch ökonomisch und so
weiter und so fort kommen wir zu Euch
ganz konkret ein Vorschlag jeweils von
dem ihr sagt der würde uns dem Frieden
wirklich näher bringen wo ihr sagt da
gehe ich sofort auf die Spitze der
Leiter und dann kann der andere darauf
reagieren du zuerst mein Vorschlag wäre
eine klare Resolution im Sicherheitsrat
die das Vorgehen der
russischen Regierungen verurteilt und
diesen Krieg sofort zu unterbinden wer
ist der das wäre finde ich einen
wichtiges Zeichen an die
Weltgemeinschaft dein Vorschlag was
glaubst Du würde uns dem Frieden am
nächst bringen meine Tiere Hilfe zu
leisten in der Form dass man sagt
Menschen die in Kriegsgebieten Leben zu
evakuieren die Freiwilligendienste dazu
also ich gehe davon dass man im
allgemeinen das militärische Personal
was vor Ort ist dazu verwendet in erster
Linie die Leute zu evakuieren die akut
unter diesem Krieg leisten in dem Sinne
dass ihre Häuser bombt werden darf ich
kurz nur fragen weil das zwischendurch
im Halbzeit viel Waffenlieferungen dafür
würdest du befürworten ich bin nicht
pauschal gegen Waffenlieferungen
natürlich
verursachen sie immer leid dass er sich
für Waffenlieferung ausspricht das hätte
ich so nicht erwartet aber es gibt
notwendiger Aktionen ja sind die
trotzdem gut bringt uns das trotzdem dem
Frieden entgegen wenn jemand eine Kugel
in den Kopf jage das kann durchaus
passieren also das hat glaube ich am
Ende oder Anfang 45 hier in Europa für
Frieden gesorgt wenn er das jetzt sagt
kommst du ihm ein Stück näher also ich
unterstütze den Aspekt der
Waffenlieferung
ich sage doch dennoch es gibt
Möglichkeiten einen Frieden zu finden
auch in dem Krieg da einige gute Aspekte
genannt wurden kann ich hier eigentlich
sehr gut stehen bleiben wo ich jetzt
stehe und das ist schon relativ weit
oben ihr beiden kommt noch mal runter
zurück zu mir auf die Couch
[Musik]
wir waren auf Leitern wir haben wirklich
viel gestritten wir hatten schon Waffen
in der Hand und haben Friedenstauben
gehisst gab's Moment wo ihr sagen würde
dann sehen wir uns schon hergekommen
ich glaube wo wir uns einig sind oder wo
wir uns sehr sehr nahe sind ist die
Frage gegen was man sozusagen kämpfen
müsste oder gegen was ist sich lohnt zu
kämpfen da wo es sich dann spaltet und
da wo es tatsächlich auch einfach ein
grundlegende grundlegende Spaltung ist
ist die Frage für was man kämpft ich
finde es wichtig noch mal ganz klar zu
sagen was Sie auch wirklich gut finde
dass eben dieses Thema Waffenlieferung
auch eine Rolle spielt dann habe ich
tatsächlich nicht gerechnet dass er sich
dafür ausspricht das finde ich gut
Hendrik weil es sehr realitätsnah ist
und da das ist für mich auch eine ganz
klare Notwendigkeit die wieder in diesem
Krieg haben um eben den entsprechenden
Part zu unterstützen und gleichzeitig
natürlich die humanitäre Hilfe steht für
mich außer Frage dass wir eben die
Bevölkerung schützen müssen
psychologisch haben wir hier natürlich
zwei völlig unterschiedliche mindset
sitzen völlig unterschiedliche
Blickwinkel auf die Welt
die kommen nicht von irgendwo du gehst
gezielt in Schulen und sprichst dort mit
jungen Menschen über die Bundeswehr was
ist die Kernbotschaft die du diesen
jungen Menschen in Deutschland mitgibst
was ist der Auftrag der Bundeswehr was
sind die NATO was sind die Europäische
Union was bedeutet das eigentlich für
einen persönlich im Auslandseinsatz zu
sein aber im Grunde genommen geht es
einfach darum Sicherheitspolitik zu
vermitteln hättest du manchmal Sorge
dass das vielleicht eine Art von mindset
bei jungen Menschen schaffen könnte dass
ich sage jetzt mal provokant eine
Kriegslust schafft davon sind wir zum
Glück so weit entfernt wir haben so eine
pazifistische grundgehaltung das
Grundgesetz von vorne bis hinten
verbietet Angriffskriege und ähnliches
also wir sind so defensiv ausgerichtet
wir haben ein Militär das im Grunde
genommen noch nie so klein war wie es
heute ist dieser Begriff kriegslos ist
völlig irreführend und auch absolut
unpassend niemand hat Lust auf Krieg in
idealen Welt bräuchten wir keine Armeen
und keine Waffen aber diese ideale Welt
gibt es einfach nicht beim Stichwort
Kriegslust muss ich an eine Studie
denken die vor einigen Jahren in
Deutschland durchgeführt wurde da wollte
man wissen wer geht zum Militär und wer
macht Zivildienst und haben sich
tatsächlich persönlichkeitsunterschiede
gefunden die zum Militär gegangen sind
die Waren emotional stabiler und auch
offener für neue Erfahrung aber die
waren auch eher wetteifern statt
kooperativ die waren eher aggressiv und
die haben sich weniger um die Gefühle
von anderen geschert Hendrik nix sofort
beim Wort Kriegslust warum
weil es eben genau das ist also ich
hatte also das was ich glaube du gehst
in Schulen ne und betreibst da
ja Agitation ich betreibe keine Werbung
ich informiere über Sicherheitspolitik
das ist ein ganz wichtiger Unterschied
genau aber die Frage ist kann man nicht
werden wenn man in eine Schule geht und
über Sicherheitspolitik im Namen und das
ganze differenziert aufzieht kann man
das durchaus tun genau
das heißt auf einladungslehrers komme
ich freiwillig also ganz kurz ich
Einladung an alle Schulen da draußen in
Deutschland würdet ihr beide auch
zusammen mal in der Schule gehen
definitiv sofort
meldet euch vielleicht klappt das wäre
wirklich differenziert oder grüße ich
absolute wenn man sich tatsächlich
differenziertes Bild machen muss dann
ist es exakt das was sie am Anfang
gesagt habe nämlich Krieg kann man nicht
reduzieren ob einfach nur Würfelspiele
Nationen Zahlen Größen und so weiter und
so fort Krieg hat immer deine notwendige
ökonomische Komponente kommt aber kein
Krieg also dann tut mir dann musst du
wirklich die Verfassung der Demokratien
in denen wir leben einfach nur
durchlesen da steht nirgends drin wir
leben nur durch Krieg das ist ein völlig
falsches ähm also sorry völlig falsche
Wahrnehmung meiner Bewertung massiver
Konflikt zwischen euch beiden weiter
sehen also ich könnte jetzt glaube ich
drei Bücher der Psychologie über
Gesichtsausdrücke schreiben alleine wenn
der eine Rede und andere gerade mal
nicht sagt weil Augenbrauen wandern
irgendwelche Köpfe hin und her
geschüttelt werden sich Lippen kräuseln
bis zum Gettnau lasst uns mal versuchen
ob wir ein Stück weit eine Annäherung
hinbekommen waren wir noch Platz
[Musik]
wir fangen an mit einem
Perspektivwechsel und der beginnt mit
dem kleinen kleidertauschen wenn ich das
mal
in dieser dienstanzugsjacke trittst du
gleich hinter das Pult und wirst uns
dann als Jan etwas erklären du bleibst
in seiner Rolle und zwar in einem
besonderen Setup wir sind in einem
Bundeswehrcamp es geht um ein Einsatz
irgendwo im Ausland wo die Demokratie in
Deutschland verteidigt werden sollte du
bist mit in diesem Einsatz und sollst
jetzt noch mal alle motivieren hier für
Deutschland zu kämpfen für Deutschland
die Waffe in die Hand zu nehmen wir sind
ein Publikum und werden applaudieren
wenn uns das gut genug gefallen hat wir
müssen uns kurz klar machen einer von
den Linksjugend zieht eine
Militäruniform an obwohl er vorher
gesagt hat niemals würde ich für
Deutschland eine Uniform anziehen und
gibt wiederum sein [ __ ] Nazis tut an den
Soldaten für mich ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Schritt weil ich glaube das
zeigt auch ja doch sie kommen sich näher
sie lassen sich zumindest auf einmal die
Rolle zu tauschen
Liebe Kameradinnen und Kameraden wenn
ihr mich fragt warum sind wir hier dann
nenne ich euch drei Dinge drei Dinge das
ist erstens Freiheit die Freiheit so zu
leben wie wir leben wollen die zweite
Sache das ist Demokratie die freie mit
Entscheidung wie wir regiert werden wer
uns regiert und wer uns vertritt und die
dritte Sache das sind unsere Werte das
sind Solidarität das ist Zusammenhalt
das ist ein Miteinander in einer
funktionierenden Gesellschaft diese drei
Dinge sind aber nur bei uns nur in
Europa nur in Deutschland vertreten für
diese drei Standbeine ziehen wir
verteidigen wir unsere Werte verteidigen
wir unsere Ansichten auch gegen eben die
Feinde unserer Ordnung
um eben aufzubauen was es aufzubauen
gilt nämlich eine Freiheit eine
Demokratie und ein funktionierendes
Wirtschaftssystem gut danke schön war
alles drin was dir wichtig war bestimmt
nicht alles ein paar Nuancen noch aber
in die richtige Richtung
gespannt ganz kurz noch ich fühle mich
sehr eklig also in dem was ich gerade
gesagt habe also noch mal Display ich
meine das nicht ernst also als ich die
Jacke von die anderen hatte und eben
diese Rede gehalten habe diese
improvisierte und dann gesagt habe ich
fühle mich eklig sozusagen in diesem
Setting ähm war das einfach eine Sache
davon das ist einfach irgendwie auch ein
persönlicher Widerspruch war und das war
einfach so der Ekel bewusst das
Schlechte zu tun ich würde fast sagen
man hätte sie angesehen ja komm zu uns
auf die Couch du bist quasi erlöst in
deiner Rolle als Jan ich gebe die Jacke
gerne wieder
weil jetzt kommt ja auch Dichter
Anspruch genauso ehrlich diese Hut jetzt
auch bitte aufzusetzen
vorbei in einer nein das ist sonst
unfair Jacke du kannst nicht von einem
linksjungen Menschen verlangen eine
Uniform Eier kannst es zumindest
falschem ist ihm wichtig ja willst das
Zeichen lieber hinten haben auch
politische Äußerungen aber wir sind bei
der Jahresversammlung der Linksjugend
Bundesverband der allergrößte das
Publikum sitzt hier und will jetzt von
dir eine flammende Rede hören lieber
Henrik ja weshalb du sagst niemals für
Deutschland die Waffe in die Hand nehmen
nicht für Deutschland den Krieg ziehen
liebe Genossen liebe Genossen ähm wir
stehen heute hier in Berlin haben einen
wichtigen Parteitag vor uns viele
wichtige Gespräche die Welt ist im
Konflikt die Welt ist im Krieg aber
es passiert nichts es passieren
grundsätzlich die falschen Sachen der
Kapitalismus als Wurzel allen Übels der
Kapitalismus fördert Ungerechtigkeit
auch dieser Ungerechtigkeit für den
Konflikte die einnehmen nehmen mehr die
werden gar nicht mehr satt
und viele viele Millionen Menschen
hungern auf Kosten anderer Leiden auf
Kosten anderer wir fördern unternehmen
wir lassen die kleinen Leute hungern wir
lassen die kleinen Leute leiden und die
Welt wird ausgebeutet auf unsere Kosten
und deshalb geht es uns am Ende besser
als andere und das ist nicht fair das
kann nicht das Ziel sein
genau ich habe nur gegen Ende geklatscht
aber ja ich kann noch mal klatschen
[Applaus]
was hat dir gefehlt was mir gefehlt hat
ist sozusagen einfach eine adäquate
Verständnis oder wirklich das
Verständnis davon wofür die Linksjugend
oder wofür die moderne linke Bewegung
steht mir hat die wirkliche Ursache
gefehlt ich habe den Kapitalismus als
Hauptperson verstanden aber das sagen
wir ja nicht mal wir sagen ja nicht mal
der Kapitalismus ist die Wurzeln allen
übelst sondern der Wert die die
Arbeitszeit die Produktionsweise das ist
nicht der Kapitalismus sondern sind die
Ursachen des Kapitalismus du hast am
Ende geklatscht ja was fand es sehr gut
was ich was ich gut fand war das was du
gegen Ende gesagt hast nämlich einfach
diese diesen Widerspruch zu zeigen nur
weil also dadurch dass wir reich sind
sind automatisch andere Leute Arm und
deswegen kannst keine Abschottung durch
Nationalismus durch Aufrüstung und so
weitergeben das fand ich gut war es ganz
kurz für dich auch eklig dazu stehen
hast du nicht eklig gefühlt im Grunde
genommen geht es ja um den
Perspektivwechsel also eklig wäre nicht
das Wort es fällt mir natürlich
dann gehen ein Stück weit schwer die
Überzeugung da reinzubringen und es gab
sogar ein kleiner Applaus zurück auf die
Couch noch einmal
[Musik]
er findet eklig du applaudierst hast du
das Gefühl dass wir hier im Laufe des
Gesprächs näher gekommen sind ich denke
das Gespräch dass im Grunde genommen auf
eine respektvollen Ebene stattfindet
bringt uns auf jeden Fall weiter war das
natürlich Horizonte erweitert was sagst
du denn seid ihr euch näher gekommen ich
glaube im Großen und Ganzen eigentlich
nicht ich finde wenn man sich näher
kommen kann dann nur durch den Blick auf
die tatsächliche Sache und ich glaube
wir haben in der Sache verschiedene
Ansicht Punkte wir sagen natürlich wir
reden über die ganz großen Themen über
die große Welt bin und trotzdem am Ende
des Tages sind es immer Menschen die
miteinander reden der Mensch Jan
[Musik]
wie wirkt auf dich also von meiner
Einschätzung bist du glaube ich sehr
sehr ordentlich sehr sehr was heißt
nicht strikt aber sehr Prinzipien getreu
und eben sehr überzeugt von dem was du
tust sonst würdest du dafür nicht bereit
sein zu sterben auf der anderen Seite
glaube ich dass dahinter eben genau
diese Verzweiflung steckt diese
Verzweiflung dass man sagt unter also
eigentlich geht es mir nicht gut aber
der Krieg ist nicht zwangsläufig einen
Ausdruck von Verzweiflung er ist
teilweise eine Notwendigkeit und wir
sind aufgeklärt genug um zu wissen dass
Krieg furchtbar ist aber an gewissen
Stellen sie Ukraine scheinbar notwendig
ich finde es interessant deine
Argumentation zu folgen nicht dass sie
inhaltlich unterstütze aber dazu folgen
du bist ähm in meiner Bewertung in einer
Situation in einer ich nenne es ganz
bewusst Bubble mir fehlt ein Stück weit
muss ich leider sagen die
Differenzierung und wenn dann nur auf
einer sehr abstrakten Ebene in einer
weiten Perspektive die aber eher
ideologisch basierend und wieder weniger
realitätspolitisch ist und da fällt mir
sehr schwer zu folgen weil ich mir sage
das kriegt schlecht das wissen wir doch
darüber müssen wir doch gar nicht reden
also wenn ich mein gesamtes Leben lang
in einem Zimmer verbracht habe und mir
dann anderes Zimmer vorstellen soll und
frage ich mich auf welcher Basis
deswegen ist Empirie schöpferische
Forschung ne also wie ich mal neu
überlegen kreativ wieder sein und neue
Gesellschaften entwerfen immer das was
dann hinten runter gelassen wird als
unwissenschaftlich irgendwie Spekulation
und sowas Krieg kann und in ganz vielen
Fällen ist er das auch tödlich sein für
Soldaten und Soldaten man max kaum
aussprechen aber das ist ja auch ein
Teil deiner Lebensrealität der du Soldat
bist er zieht in den Krieg du bist jetzt
sein Freund und gibst ihm was mit und
bitte so schwer das Feld nur Positives
weil was will man so einem Freund sonst
jetzt mitgeben
auch wenn wir in der Sache verschieden
sind auch wenn wir unterschiedliche
Ansichten haben was notwendig ist und
was nicht wünsche ich mir dass du wieder
zurückkommst ich wünsche mir dass du
deinen Weg gehst und auf deinem Weg
nicht stirbst sondern tatsächlich mir
uns allen erhalten bleibt in der Form
wie du es bist und umgekehrt du lässt ja
auch ein Freund zurück Hendrik ich
gehe in den Einsatz ich fand es
unglaublich stark dass wir uns
kennengelernt haben dass wir trotz
anfänglicher unterschiedlicher Meinungen
ja auf der freundschaftlichen Ebene
zusammengefunden haben ich denke gerne
daran zurück ich reflektiere unsere
Gespräche und hoffe dass wir das in
wenigen Monaten besser Gesundheit
vorsetzen können noch seither keine
Freunde nehme ich an und trotzdem haben
wir jetzt die Situation der echten
Verabschiedung wie läuft die zwischen
euch ab macht's gut also war schön okay
also ja vielen Dank für das Gespräch ich
würde mich freuen wenn wir uns auf der
Diskussionsebene wieder treffen
vielleicht gibt es ja bei der Jungs noch
die Möglichkeit Zeit einmal darüber zu
sprechen und das ganze differenziert zu
bewerten wofür die Bundeswehr steht ich
denke die Impulse die mir Henrik gegeben
hat die Inhalte die haben natürlich mein
Horizont erweitert und vielleicht eine
Position besser verstehen zu können
warum er so argumentiert und was seine
Grundlage des Denkens ist unsere Meinung
haben da trotzdem unterschiedliche
Positionen und ich denke das hat sich
auch im Laufe der Sendung nicht sehr
groß verändert nach dem Gespräch ist Jan
für mich immer noch ein Bundeswehrsoldat
in erster Linie von dem ich denke dass
er seine Individualität freiwillig
aufgegeben hat von dem ich denke dass er
in der Position in der er ist nicht mehr
in der Lage ist mündige Entscheidungen
zu treffen sondern tatsächlich empfehlen
zu gehorchen
Nationen zu gehorchen Staaten zu
gehorchen danke dass ihr beiden damals
weiter alles Gute bitteschön der Angriff
auf die Ukraine hat so viel verändert
und so so so viele Fragen aufgeworfen
und ich finde die Antworten von beiden
heute unglaublich spannend auch
bereichern wenn du das auch so siehst
teilt auch dieses Video
[Musik]